I think witness has robbed many people
of compassion and replaced it with moral
superiority compassion and empathy is
paramount to any social movement and so
any form of progress once you have
compassion and empathy you can often see
that you have a lot more in common with
people than you do apart and it's the
system under which we live in they're
forcefully tries to group us on our
differences what is radical is kindness
what is radical is understanding that's
the one thing they don't want us to do
is to understand each other arguing with
each other isn't actually radical it so
it's very conformist actually hello
welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster i'm konstantine
kitchen and this is the show for you if
you want honest conversations with
fascinating people our guest today is a
fashion stylist and writer Aisha I can't
be welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me oh it is so good to have you
here we've been waiting for this moment
for a while I've been talking about
getting you on the show for ages so glad
to have you here for anyone who doesn't
already know who you are tell us a
little bit about who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
that brings you sitting here mm-hmm
well I'm actually a fashion stylist and
that's how most people have got to know
me through the internet and maybe around
2013-14 I started using my voice a
little more on the Internet
I had a situation in my personal life
where someone really close to me died
and that really changed my ideas and my
outlook on the world and I guess I was
just sort of searching for answers in
really strange places I mean I even did
the whole kind of religious route like
spent some time in like churches trying
to find answers spend some time like
searching through like my family their
Muslim and so I spent some time trying
to kind of get my my head around Islam
and things like that all kinds of things
all sorts of belief systems I traveled
through and then eventually I just kind
of felt like you know the best thing to
do is just be myself you know I didn't
feel like I needed any sort of belief
system
to express my views and so maybe in
around 2018 I think this is how maybe
you guys know me I think it was 2018 I
had recognized there was a new sort of
belief system that was taking hold you
know of a lot of my friends and a lot of
the people that I was around and even
when I was kind of looking for something
to believe in if you like I just
realized that a lot of those people
didn't often have self-awareness they
often weren't rooted in just I don't
know some of the fundamental principles
that I was interested in and then I
recognized this new thing kind of taking
over everywhere and maybe some people
call it woken us some people call it
identitarian politics there's lots of
different names for it but I made a
video it was called or as interviewed it
was called the problem with wotus I was
just speaking my mind I didn't know
anything that I was saying was
potentially controversial and yeah Here
I am you know what we might stick a
little bit of that at the front so
people can see what you're talking about
when one of the things I wanted to talk
to you about because it's fascinating to
me is you and I were having a
conversation about you coming on the
show and we've been talking probably
about a year now yeah we have been and
we set up times and didn't quite work
and and and and in the end I kind of
confronted you a little bit I was like
hey how have we not managed to make this
happen and you were like you know what
I've been reluctant to come on mm-hmm
why is that
and my reluctance to come on it's funny
because that's the entire reason why I
made the video or why I think the
interview resonated with a lot of people
is there's an idea now and it's a quite
a prevalent idea that if you speak to
someone who has the so-called wrong
views then you are wrong by adjacent and
but it's it's a really silly idea to say
the least because you know if you're not
talking to people who think differently
then you're speaking to the choir you
know and that doesn't make sense because
the world isn't made up of people who
think like us
so I was somewhat reluctant and then I
kept thinking to myself well if you
don't go on and talk to people then
you're not being a woman of your own
principles you know and I will speak to
anybody anybody that's reasonable
anybody that's open to conversation or
who can hear something that they
disagree with without that meaning that
someone is hateful without sort of
deducting their that means someone is
hateful those are the kinds of
conversations I wanted to have and so
when you wanted me about it I was like
yeah you know what I I have to do this
because you know there's a lot going on
and we're not talking to each other and
I think that's a huge part of the
problem though the thing that I find
actually really upsetting is how if you
see a person who's an ethnic minority
particularly though if they're black the
moment they come out as not having woke
or liberal views it's almost like
they've betrayed their entire race they
use horrendous racist language yeah
smear them all the rest of it why is
that
I think people think that if you don't
share their views then you are somehow
letting the side down and you can only
think this because they have a very
narrow conception of what it means to be
black or whatever identity it might be
which in itself is you know at least the
form of prejudice if you don't want to
call it anything else and it's harmful
and there are many perspectives and ways
to view an issue and if we are
cancelling out one of those voices
because they are inconvenient then we're
cheating ourselves out of like you know
expanding our awareness and you said
it's prejudice don't you think it's a
form of racism the fact that you know
somebody will look you know look at
somebody of a particular color and go oh
therefore you know you were black
therefore you should be this you should
be that you should be whatever else
instead of the fact that they're a human
being which being black has nothing to
do with their politics or whatever else
yeah well I guess because in this sort
of ideology of you like you can't just
be black being black isn't actually just
a skin colour and maybe that's what I
think a lot of people don't understand
being black is innately political to
these people and and what they mean by
that is something I understand
is you know if you are black in this
conception because of how other people
view you which may not always be
positive they feel like the response to
that has to be innately political or
that you have to be political that is
how that you are showing up for your
race if you like and so because they
don't think it's just a skin color they
think being black means that you have to
be political it's a political statement
what do you think I don't think black is
I think you know it's it's an immutable
characteristic you know it could have
been anything else I don't think my race
defines me in any way or any aspect of
my identity really that's not the way
that I think of course being black means
that like I guess I might have a bit
more of a vested interest in some of the
issues around race and racism but no I
don't think beyond that that it informs
much of my interest so World News I was
just gonna finish this train of thought
because so there's this idea that if you
are an ethnic minority that you have to
be sort of liberal but it doesn't also
take into account like for instance my
mother is from South America everybody
can drink now but you know and she came
to his country as a first generation
immigrant but like a lot of
first-generation immigrants she's
incredibly conservative you know she's
religious she's not only conservative
fiscally but socially it doesn't take
into account that actually a lot of
first-generation and ethnic minority
communities are incredibly socially
conservative so thinking they're going
to be whoa kids it's just wrong isn't it
yeah no it doesn't and I think it's
because we have in many ways or sort of
downloaded the American discourse around
race and we've imported it here and and
it's not sort of like a
one-size-fits-all tesha you know but
because we kind of use it that way we're
not necessarily embracing reality
because you are right you know my
parents are Nigerian I grew up with my
mother and she is very socially
conservative you know that's very much
yeah that's very much her worldview
although she votes on the left but you
know there's even there's
wasted to even look at hip-hop if you
like you know as somewhat conservative
in its ideals if you think about the
fact that it's very much about
competition you know it's very much
about like you know consumerism it's
serialism like it it's very much you
know you can even denigrate the pork
just completely you can just be out
there and just be like you're poor so
you're a piece of [ __ ] because if people
think but it's a very pull yourself up
by your bootstraps for us again you know
that's quite innate in hip-hop and so
actually you know socially conservative
ideas kind of exist in in many different
aspects of different you know black
communities mmm-hmm so I don't even know
where to go I mean one you you say
you're a fashion stylist and a writer
but when I watch and observe what you
put out that I'd say you're a
philosopher if anything that's kind
that's I hope you don't think I'm
overstating it but that's definitely my
feeling I producers nodding over there
so I'm right basically is what I'm
saying you're wrong about your I get to
define one of those things I think a
philosopher is one of those things you
can't call yourself you know if you have
anything like that that's in your being
I think that should be for other people
to decide I just maybe don't get enough
and I think too much yeah so you do
think a lot and and very very well about
these issues so one of the things that I
wanted to talk to you about is something
my wife and I talk about all the time
which is how much of this victimhood
culture that you know woke Nasseri much
has embraced and driven forward is about
people projecting their own personal
[ __ ] their trauma the the difficulties
whatever and and I'm not even talking
about like experiences that you have as
an adult I'm talking about when you're
five years old
you know and then taking that and
projecting that onto the world and as we
know from all the psychological research
if you come into the world with a wither
with a filter
you see that reflecting back at you and
this is something you talk about very
well so tell us more about that yes and
this is why in what I tried to put out
in my message if I can call it that
I very much preached for the need for
self awareness just as much as we have
social awareness I think because we have
maybe we're sort of overexposed socially
but we're not necessarily that engaged
with ourselves to know where a lot of
our ideas are coming from and so I do
think there is it's not surprising that
let's say the mental health discussion
rose to the mainstream at the same time
as woke nurse you know I think there's
something to look at there you know a
lot more people are you know
acknowledging anxiety depression and
it's not just about you know anxiety and
depression can also be can also impacts
the way that you see yourself the way
that you see it over the world they the
reason why they can be troublesome
states to being apart from feeling
terrible is that it can kind of it can
distort reality you know it can very
much distort reality and so there is so
much and it also there's a reason as to
why the word trauma has almost become a
buzzword some people might say you know
I'm sure if there was so Mike you know
dates are on like how much the word
trauma comes up on Twitter I think it
would be extremely high and so when you
don't have an outlet to to sort of deal
with your issues to process your issues
I think some people can choose an
ideology or a belief system or maybe
wanting to change the world because I
guess it's a lot easier to want to
change the world than it is to look at
yourself you know which is why we often
talk about accountability I notice
everyone is always talking about you
know you have to be accountable you have
to be accountable but no one ever spokes
about responsibility you know
responsibility is a bit of a dirty word
it seems to a lot of people and again
because it's easier to demand
accountability
from other people than it is to take
responsibility for the things that
you've been through and you know that
the problem with victimhood and you know
there's a very big difference between
victimized and victimhood you know
victimized is something we could have
all felt that different points but
victimhood is a state it's a state it's
almost a philosophy within itself it's a
way of perceiving the world and it comes
with its own form of entitlement and the
funny thing is is you know is the word
narcissism gets a lot of flack on the
internet and you know a lot of people
talk about being victims of narcissistic
abuse but power of narcissism is
victimhood you know and and so I think
that a lot of people because they they
don't have the means or they don't have
the what would I call it because I think
to recognize that you know a lot of your
ideas are driven by a certain acts that
you have you know against the world or
you know or gripe that you have I think
that can be quite confronting and we
live in a culture where everybody wants
to feel emotionally safe constantly all
the time
and so these two things they don't marry
well you know like being honest with
yourself and wanting to feel safe you
know so these don't really work and so
that's why I think we're in a state
where people can't truly be that honest
about where a lot of their ideas are
coming from and I know this a little bit
because I guess I was in it you know
there was a point where I had swallowed
a lot of these ideas which is maybe why
I'm quite passionate about speaking
about them because I know how blinding
they can be you know and we we sort of
glamorized anger and rage and the thing
about anger and rages is blinding you
know like a lot of people will justify
the wrong things that they do because
they were angry I was angry I didn't
mean to punch you you know like and so
it's it's blinding and so I think anger
can be maybe a an interesting place or a
productive place maybe to occasionally
visit because it can make us productive
and it can makers it can spark ideas and
creativity but it it can't be a final
resting place and so I think when
yeah swallowing ideas that you know it's
good to be angry all the time you know
and make everything is the fault of
everyone else you know everything that
has gone wrong in your life is to do
with this person these are very
seductive ideas and when I was sort of
entrenched in some of these beliefs yeah
it was completely a distortion of
reality you know the fact that I had
worked my way and become a stylist and I
guess as far as I guess as far as any
sort of standard metric would go I was
fairly successful maybe you could say
you know that doesn't mean that all my
problems were gone but you know I was
doing well you know but that didn't
matter it didn't matter that I was doing
well because someone else was doing
better you know and and I think this is
the way a lot of people have concert you
know conceive the world and do to this
identity or this ideology is addictive
yes I think it can be addictive yes
because it's comfortable it's what you
know I don't think I don't necessarily
try not to demonize it too much and
that's hard because it's annoying you
know it can be very annoying but I have
to remember that you know I've been in a
similar state I would say I wasn't so
combative when I was there because
that's just not my personality
I didn't think all disagreement men hate
however it can be addictive because
built into the ideology if you like of
victimhood is innocence if you're a
victim then you're innocent if you're a
victim then you're innately virtuous and
so that is and if you're a victim then
everyone else is the oppressor and
everybody else is the aggressor so it's
a state that's quite seductive because
it's one where people don't ever truly
have to look at themselves and as we may
know that looking at your source is hard
and you mentioned the word of being
oppressed and you're someone who who
takes a lot of care when you use words
and when you think about words and you
talked a lot about oppression versus
discrimination just break that down for
us yeah I mean I've always paid
attention to the language that I use and
for one because you know even if I had a
platform of just the hundred people
that's still a hundred people who were
listening to me who could potentially be
influenced
and if you care about people who you
make them vulnerable or the most
vulnerable I think how you speak to them
and what you allow them to believe of
themselves and their reality is very
important and so for me I've always
wondered you know like is what I have
faced you know oppression or is it
discrimination because the the two don't
seem to be the same to me
discrimination seems to be something
that anybody could face for any reason
you know you probably have yeah and yeah
definitely you know if you're someone
who's over way if you've got ginger hair
like when I was in school like those
guys just got ripped you know if you're
considered to be unattractive it all of
these kind of things can allow you to be
discriminated against your voice how you
speak your accent all these sorts of
things and so and I have you know I've
definitely had people especially when I
was in school I I grew up in South
Hampton my school was predominantly
white there weren't many black people
there and so there were people who let's
say made fun of my hair oh you've got
trolls hair and there were people who
you know made fun of like my features
and stuff like that because they were
different and at the time of course it
was hurtful but it wasn't if I'm honest
truly different to anything that the
ginger kid you know I wasn't going
through and I would call that
discrimination I wouldn't call that
oppression I think if you can go online
and you can call out your government and
you can say anything about white men and
you can say anything about any people
with very little repercussion I think
that might be the evidence that you know
you might not be oppressed you make that
point and look it's a very I mean so a
contentious issue to get into but we're
gonna have to get into it which is you
know you mentioned you can say whatever
you want about white men and let's be
honest you can say things about certain
groups of people that you can't say that
about others is that sustainable no I
don't think it makes sense to talk about
people in a way that you wouldn't accept
yourself because human psychology means
for every action there is a reaction and
there's a consequence so if people feel
like one group is allowed to get away
with a certain type of
havior that another one isn't that's not
going to work well you know it's not
it's all because not everybody is right
I mean not everybody is versed in racial
history or racial politics not everybody
cares we can't make everybody care so no
matter what your justification is for
why you believe it's okay to completely
denigrate an entire demographic there
will be a consequence to that so if you
want to do it go for it but what I would
ask is it's not constructive and if you
want to be constructive and helpful for
the people that you wish to help this
might be a way that you are in a
completely sort of being self defeating
there wow so you're saying hashtag kill
all white men constructive you know it
might not be the best PR camp
hello guys and welcome to a new setting
for the adverts it is far out they'll
pom pom now we've got a new advert this
week it is
Express VPN I know catchy name and not
just that also very interesting for the
lads at the back now gentlemen it's
always going to be the gentleman I
addressed this question to you ever been
online searching for things that you
don't want other people to know about we
know what we're talking about here
gentlemen don't we we're talking about
Port Peterborough United maybe you just
ashamed of the fact that you support
Peter Brook whatever it may be
expressvpn have a solution for you now
there's probably some smart person
listening to this don't mate come on
what do you just see using kognito
that's what they do that's what
everybody does ladies are none the wiser
it's all good well here's the thing
gentlemen incognito mode isn't really
all it's cracked up to be
let me explain the thing is guys
incognito mode does not hide your
browsing history I don't care how many
times you've deleted your search history
people can still find out what you've
been watching or listening to your
internet service provider knows what you
do that's right you're listening to this
and you've got a lovely little blush on
your cheeks and that's why even
at home I never go online without using
expressvpn right so it doesn't matter
who your internet server service
provider is if it's Verizon Comcast or
any other of the my root of options in
the USA is absolutely legal for them to
sell your search history to advert
providers so everybody in the corporate
world will know what a dirty little
so-and-so you are expressvpn is an app
that reruns your internet through their
servers so that your internet service
provider can't see the naughty little
sites that you visit and expressvpn also
keeps all of your information secure by
encrypting 100% of your data with the
most powerful encryption tools available
so nobody will notice the naughtiness
all you need to do is visit my
exclusively Express VPN dot-com slash
trigger and you get an extra three
months on a one-year package that's e.x
PR ESS VPN comm slash trigger to find
out more simply go to the website
Express VPN dot-com slash trigger and
then you'll be able to hide from
everybody the fact that you watch this
show the thing that I worry about when
they do things like that or you know
someone tweets always just another old
white man mm-hmm
is essentially you're dividing the races
you're creating a divide between the
races so there there are gonna be people
who look at that and go well you know
what I'm not gonna listen to what you
say anymore because I'm white therefore
I'm wrong and then you've got a small
very toxic minority who look at that
robbed their hands with lingo we can
create division here yeah yeah exactly I
think people underestimate how much
people want to be heard and how much
people want to belong it's part of the
reason why we have this ideology that is
so sort of you know dominant in the
mainstream right now because to to not
be a part of that is to isolate
yourself and potentially leave yourself
open to accusations of fascism racism
all of the phobias and so when you are
telling people that they can't speak
because of their skin colour or when
you're speaking about someone in a way
that you would no way have within
yourself you don't recognize that you
also are radicalizing people you're
pushing people over to a certain side
because if people no longer feel let's
say that they have a voice on the left
and people don't want to listen to them
on the left they will go somewhere else
I mean the arguments of that is well I
guess if they could so easily be swayed
then they were never true leftist and I
don't think people are truly truly
appreciating human psychology there you
know we want to be heard but it's also I
mean you say it's so easy if they so
easily move to the left it's not easy
it's taken some people 10 years to make
the journey from being oh I'm super
lefty to oh wait [ __ ] like on this
particular issue I I'm just not wanted I
mean look at JK Rowling right
Little Miss lefty all the time you know
all the right opinions you know all the
all the right causes supporting all the
stuff there's one issue and this is what
I've been talking about for some time
they will always find a way in which you
don't fit mm-hmm and so that journey
it's not been like oh this you know it's
so easy to get people to move it takes a
hell of a lot of badgering and battering
and you know offending and whatever to
get people to make that transition and I
see that I think we see that happening
right now a lot of people I you know
will take you around is a good example a
lot of people are gonna be on her side
now in a way that they might not have
been before because you're forcing them
to make a choice between what they know
to be true and what they think is the
right thing am i no no you're right
there may be what I meant is it's so
easy as I meet so many more young people
who almost see being on the writers like
quite the counterculture thing to do you
know which is interesting because you
know you know like conservatism you know
sort of symbolizes tradition then
and keeping think keeping the order so
it's not necessarily the most Rockstar
thing to do you know a lot of young
people are sort of seeing it that way
now and so I think maybe for them it may
be easier in JK Rowling's case yeah I
think people do people who believe they
have the good politics people who
believe they are the good people they
are way too quick to assume nefarious
intention to anybody that doesn't share
their beliefs and it's going to be a
downfall it's not constructive and it's
manipulative I think I think it's very
manipulative to call all disagreement
hate you know there used to be a time
where we would acknowledge and accept
that let's say if you were religious
you probably didn't really believe in
homosexuality you know you didn't
believe that those people had a right to
marry you disagreed with them beat it
necessarily wouldn't they hate to do you
just thought well this is their religion
this is their belief you know but we
can't seem to do that anymore you know
the the gender issue and the transgender
discourse mainstream at the moment is
complicated if I might say and some
might say it's quite simple you know but
however the idea that sex and gender sex
and gender are separate is something I
think majority people probably still
believe in you know because if you don't
spend your time on switzer and if you
haven't got like you know a Gender
Studies degree and if you you know
aren't sort of reading a lot of the
contemporary gender texts then you
probably will think this and so to
assume that anybody who wants to fight
for that category it's hateful well then
you know you're gonna be thinking about
that's a lot of black people a lot of
people that we also on one on one breath
say that we want to help and that we
should protect you know and so I think
especially on that issue as it is very
contentious people have to start
listening to each other and I think as
long as you're accusing each other and
calling people names and and trying to
smear reputations it's not conducive to
the movement it's not
conducive to the trans children that you
believe are vulnerable I don't think
it's it's just not productive you know
that's what I deal with I don't
necessarily offer them care necessarily
too much about like whether it's right
or wrong because that can be subjective
to lots of different people but what's
constructive and I don't think as we can
quite clearly see everything that's been
happening in that area has been very
constructive but there's also these
people and I've seen them myself and
they're people in my industry who have
for want of a better term jumped on this
debate made it more toxic in order just
to push their own brand what they do
increase their followers and so on and
so forth yeah and how big an effect do
you think that has you think it's just
one voice or do you think that has a
real sizable impact what's that so like
people jumping on yeah and then going
you know what silence is violence you
know is people going you know like all
white people if you don't you know
support every aspect of black lives
matter you are part of the problem
yeah again this is not round this is not
grounded in reality to me you know there
are a myriad issues that we are silent
on mm-hmm
so if we're gonna say silence is
violence then let's just also keep that
a message and narrative consistent and
acknowledge that all violent men you
know because there are lots of things
that we are silent on that affect a lot
of people even black and brown people
there was a brilliant weed the other day
some people came up with the idea that
silence is consent and they make
t-shirts thanking silence is concerned
someone just retweeted and when you
might want to rethink
so yes I think I came so the thing
that's quite different now is that what
we post on social media can have a
real-life impact in our real life so
offline and so more than ever I think
people are incentivized you want to
appear to be good people I mean I guess
broadly speaking we all want to be good
people however being an honest person is
something that some people value or
prioritize on the same level you know
and I think people who want to be good
people and honest people they're always
going to have some tension then you know
because if you're honest with yourself
you can't always be good for everyone
else and so people jumping on the
bandwagon of movements ideas theories
that they don't understand don't know
what they've rooted in this is quite
destructive because for one of a better
word you're you talk you don't know what
you're talking about
literally you don't actually know what
you're talking about you don't know
where these ideas come from you don't
know what the impact of these ideas are
on people because you're not necessarily
from that community you're not someone
who's ever had these issues let's say
with a lot of the the trans discussion a
lot of the people that we would say are
hateful and I don't necessarily think I
think hate is a work that we do shout to
easily and again I think we do it quite
manipulatively because once you brand
someone is hateful then you don't have
to listen to them anymore you know and
and you sort of and you spread that idea
but a lot of the people who let's say
have questions if you like about
mainstream let's say transgender
discussion and I say mainstream and I
and I and I I really want to sing all
that out because that's not how every
trans person feels that's not the way
that every trans person is is viewing
that discussion but a lot of those women
that we're calling hateful themselves
had experienced gender dysphoria you
know and it's it's from that space that
they're speaking from you know like
someone like me who has definitely at
some points swallowed a little bit of
woke ideology or at least this ideology
that very much sees the world in this
black
since the reason why I am critical of it
you know and asked us to reconsider
those ideas is because I I've had them
and I've noticed how destructive they
were to me how exhausting they were how
how much I just had an inability to
truly look at myself in those moments
and the only person who doesn't benefit
from that is me and so I think that yeah
well you're basically saying if I'm
hearing you correctly is being workers
bad for your own health and well-being I
think it is bad for your mental health
and well-being because we have to be
able to embrace the gray because a lot
of life exists in the gray you know if
we if we want to say that everybody who
doesn't agree with us is hateful then we
have to get rid of many of our own
family members you have many of the
children that we're going to bring up
your knee into the world it's just not
practical or realistic okay I can tell
you fully integrated into Britain
because your slogan is embrace the grey
you mentioned can I mean you keep making
this point over and over about
constructive and unconstructive helpful
and unhelpful so with that filter on
what do you make of the current protests
that we're seeing and the black lives
matter organization as it's impacting
the world right now
I understand why people want to protest
and I think if people want to protest
for whatever they believe in they should
always have the right to do that do you
have the right to pressure people into
doing that I don't think so if people
don't want to do that does that say
something innately about their morality
I do not think so it's very likely that
a lot of us don't necessarily know in
Britain let's say no let's say the the
plight of a you know a typical Pakistani
woman in her village you know and I was
not knowing her plight does that reflect
you know our morality I don't think so
or the fact that we're not speaking for
her issues I don't
so people can protest when it comes to
the rights and aspects which some people
justify again I come back to you know it
constructive right now we are still in
the middle of a pandemic and if we're
saying that you know black and brown
people are more susceptible to dying as
a result of this and people are mass
gathering when before we were saying
that you know we're not ready to go back
to work and they were saying all of
these things it just seems to again it's
not consistent and I think you know
let's say with the writing a lot of
people a lot of people's businesses who
are minorities they've lost their
businesses I don't see how that can be
beneficial to them I think if we
acknowledge that there is a problem with
the American police in terms of
brutality and which actually does affect
people of all races and if there's a
disproportionate let's say it is
proportional 'evil of violence against
black men having young black men come
face to face with the police you know
because of the riots knowing that they
use brute force again I don't know if
that is constructive protest it's going
to happen especially when we are not
necessarily sure of all of the facts you
know and when we are more grounded in
that same narrative than concrete
reality and even when we are you know
grounded in reality people want to
protest that's just gonna happen but I
think the way to do it there is a way to
do it and I think there's a way to do it
that can also be sort of undermining of
your overall goals and why do you think
it is with the black lives matter
movement people we all agree that of
course black lives matter of course they
do but the black lives matter movement
and the organization is very very
political now someone who comes from a
country where I've seen socialism rise
and fail in the most awful way possible
I read some of what they say and I'm
you know what why is it that the moment
I say that I'm gonna go to say - Anton
[ __ ] cut that bit immediately but why
is that that you that you can support
black lives matter but the actual
political organisation if you criticize
it you feel like you're done because
people have made black lives matter
synonymous with being black or black
people and people have almost framed it
as if if you want to not be a racist
then you can only do it through this
filter you can only do it through let's
say the the theory of anti racism or
through black lives matter that's not
true you know like a lot of us can not
be racist you know like you know I'm
sure you guys have managed to get here
today
you know without necessarily
perpetuating any racism you know and a
lot of us can do this without
necessarily having to embrace an
organization that might be counter to a
lot of the things that we value and
that's not necessarily again you know we
can't use racism like a paracetamol and
put it on everything you know we can't
do that it doesn't work you know and so
it's just not it's just not the case
even if we want it to be that everybody
who doesn't agree with a certain way of
doing things is doing it because they
think that you're an inferior race but
yeah I think because you know black
lives matter is huge its global I think
we just genuinely think that this is the
only way that you can support black
lives this is the only way that you can
not be racist again I think it comes
back to the fact that this ideology or
this worldview if you want to call it
that is very black-and-white you know
you know excuse the pun but yeah I think
that's why do you support blog post
matter I well not necessarily in any
sort of meaningful senses in I'm not
tweeting about it I'm not let's say hash
tagging it on my Instagram I I didn't
post the black box although I guess the
black box wasn't about black lives
matter I think
we we learned I I support black people
and I support people being honest and I
support people being grounded in
rationality and facts I don't support
people putting fear into people who fit
into people's lives who are already
vulnerable for whatever means I support
black people in there's many ways that I
can do that I support people actually
but I can support people through means
that are not that that doesn't work for
me see so let's take what you've just
said which i think is an eminently
sensible reasonable saying balance
statement if you would I mean you might
get in trouble just for saying it here
you might but if we will know that if I
I would tell Francis was to go on the
radio tomorrow on TV tomorrow and make
that exact statement I support black I
support all people actually you know you
know and you say well I don't
necessarily wear you think and and and
which i think is how all human beings
ought to be right you don't just you
know bend the knee and and go for
whatever it is there's being shoved down
your throat you think well let's look at
the website let's look at what the
statements are lesser oh do what they
want to demolish the nuclear family
maybe that's nothing they want to get
rid of the police maybe that's not for
me they want to abolish capitalism you
know maybe that's not like you take all
those things then you go well on balance
I don't support this organization but I
support black people and actually I I
want all people to you know why is it
that for you know for one of us to say
that you know it's over if you like
because well you know we don't know I
might get in trouble for that so I guess
what my real question is why should any
of us get in trouble for that because
again we we have a very simplistic
understanding of human beings and this
is something about that worldview very
much encourages and so we do this thing
called mind
and so what we here so you they might
you might say well I support black
people however I don't support the aims
that are listed in the black lives
matter sort of yeah whatever a manifesto
whatever yeah I don't support that their
manifesto what they hear is I don't I
don't want black people to live you know
like you know that we're hearing
different things I think people don't
necessarily listen to language because
we think that we understand who people
are you know this is you must be that
person if you don't believe this again
it's just a very simplistic view of
human beings because they have a very
simplistic understanding of themselves
if you had a complicated understanding
of yourself and if you knew the gray
that exists within you and if you knew
that you had the ability to let's say
understand an idea without necessarily
and maybe even yes you could say if you
knew you have the ability to understand
an idea but that doesn't mean that you
condone an idea if they knew that then
they wouldn't necessarily think that
nobody else had the capacity to do such
a thing right so you're saying really is
it's the simplicity of their thinking
because any you know the the inability
to accept complication I think is the
inability to accept it within yourself
yeah complexity rather I mean and the
thing that I find troubling
about all of these movements is is the
performance of morality aspect of them
just going on my Instagram the number of
white middle-class people embrace this
is everything that I'm learning today on
Bracy you're like who is this for who is
this for these six Instagram stories and
it's painful it's painful to watch and
honestly ever since this is started I go
on social media I reply to people I post
if I need to I don't scroll I don't look
I can't bear to and the thing is I don't
hold I mean I it's not that I miss it
well I'm frustrated with people I'm not
angry at people necessarily
they're doing what they're told because
if you don't do this then you are an a
racist you know if you don't do this
then you want me to die this is what the
view is that you want to see and so
because people have bought into that
idea this is what they think they need
to do and I can't bear it because any
sort of person of my orientation just
finds it completely condescending and
you know but it's also sad for those
individuals because you can't actually
win you can buy the books you can do all
of this but as soon as you put one foot
out of line you know they're going to
attack you and they'll do it mercilessly
you know because it's not it's not about
revolution or restructure or anything
like that it's often just about revenge
you know and so you can read all the
books that you like you know it's not
going to change you know you're
immutable characteristics as far as
people who are committed to seeing the
world in a certain way of concern so
that's why it's saddens me as well
because I get it you know I'm sure it's
well intended and I'm sure part of it is
you know let's say reputation control
you know damage limitation but I'm sure
you know it's coming from a place where
you know this is what I've been told to
do so this is what I should do but again
the problem with the the statement
listen to all black people or listen to
black people is the suggestion that all
black people think the same because what
happens if you listen to let's say you
read one book and this book says
something else then where I what do you
do now this book says something
completely different about how to
counter racism or how to be as a white
person in this fight against racism
there is no genuine general consensus
you know when it comes to a lot of these
ideas there isn't I disagree with a lot
of my black friends I disagree with a
lot of my white friends and that's the
way it should be you know the goal I
hope is that we can disagree
respectfully and that we can maybe ask
each other
why do
feel that way you know what rather than
saying like you feel this way because of
this I mean it doesn't take much to ask
why do you feel that way you know why do
you have this stance or you know what
brought you to this stance yeah that's
that's not hard to do it's interesting
to me to talk about this idea of
listening to black people I don't I
don't hear many people like you on my
television I'm not that i watch much
television but you know you see the
clips that are code do the rounds on
social media you see how these come you
know I've been on TV a number of times
talking about some of these issues a
little bit with with on the other side
of me there's people who you don't they
don't sound like you yeah they don't say
what you say yeah they have a very
different view and that view seems to be
the only view that a black person gets
to have on TV you know you either you
know let's be honest a race baiter or
you're not there to every now and again
you get somebody coming on but broadly
speaking that is so when we talk about
listening to black but why are they
listen to you well why do they have to
go on YouTube and what you hear instead
of seeing you on their TV screens
because you've got a very interesting
tonight shut up we need two views well
they call people with my view tokens or
they say that it's a privilege for you
to have or they say that you know this
view doesn't represent X Y Zed you know
that she doesn't speak for us you know I
don't actually speak for you I speak for
myself but you know I'm sure there are a
lot of people who also have a similar
idea and there's going to be of course
like subtle differences in things but
yeah it's because it's it's politically
incorrect to have a person like me on
the show because I don't know I mean for
one there is a big there is a war on
reason you know and there is a war on
what I would cost common sense you know
everything I'm saying I don't think is
necessarily profound I am saying that
you have to treat people how you wish to
be treated you know 101 we teach
toddlers this but you know I guess this
view doesn't shake as many people up
you know and I guess whether it's about
ratings or whether it's about pushing a
certain narrative for whatever reason
they want to make people believe that
people like me don't exist and if we do
exist that we know we must be Tories or
we must be and privileged both of which
I am NOT or at least I did not grow up
you know you know with us and so yeah I
mean considering you know a lot of
people would like to say you know black
people aren't a monolith you know like
this is a slogan one of the slogans I
hear often but as soon as you act like
you're not a monolith then you know they
they quite quickly remind you why you
should be so it's a very confused way of
seeing the world I think if people have
I think of a lot of mainstream news
channels have people on who are saying
the opposite to what I'm saying then it
looks like they are doing the work you
know as they're told to do someone like
me I think they don't think is
representative the it's interesting that
you say that one of the phrases that I
keep hearing and I don't know why it
makes me feel uneasy uneasy is the words
be an ally as if we're in this perpetual
war maybe maybe that's my white
privilege that I have never seen this
war happen it's yeah where does that
come from
because I guess we a lot of people do
feel like you know existing is a
battlefield
you know you very much hear sometimes
people say you know I've had white
people say to me you know ie sure as a
black woman I am sure you know you just
waking up is like you know a
revolutionary act you know wake up with
you know these mile an clock just like
anybody else I wouldn't have called it
revolutionary however you know there is
this idea and and he says it to me
trying to be complimentary and blessing
you know I think he's sweet he's just
talking to the wrong person you know I
don't see it as complimentary but I
understand you know his intention and so
when people are convinced that they are
living on a battlefield for whatever
reason because we can all we can all
whip ourselves up into any folks fate of
reality that we like well then yeah I
guess you know the idea of having allies
rather than friends hmm you know is is
is more appealing
I don't need an ally personally I don't
want an ally I'd like to talk to people
I like connections with people
acquaintances associates friends I don't
know what an ally is and allied to me
seems to be someone who has to pander to
everything I say because I'm black that
seems condescending I don't want that
and also my view doesn't represent what
every black person thinks I don't want
that if you're a friend or if you're an
associate or someone that I can share a
connection with surely that's enough you
know I don't need you to fight my
battles there's nothing you can do
that's going to liberate me talk to your
nan if you want or don't you know I
really don't care I don't you know it's
it's almost you know it's people have a
democratic right to dislike me you know
if you want you know even for my race if
you want you don't have a right to
obstruct me you know and that's what I
care about you know but most people
think that their cultures are superior
you know most people feel you know more
important than the next person I guess
there's a part of living where we may
have to do you know which is why maybe
we won't go into the fire you know I
like to save someone so we can save
ourselves I don't know I just I've never
never felt the need for in our line
every time that someone has tried to be
an ally to me I've just felt incredibly
patronized and it's okay because I get
it you know I get that you're coming
from a place where for one you've been
told to come from and also that you want
to help but to want to help is to assume
that being black as a disadvantage to me
orestes oom that being black worse is a
disability to me you know and I find
those ideas
again troublesome to say the least so
how do we make this better
that's a shitty question it's a good
question because maybe I exactly maybe
I'll try to answer it I think we need
courage you know I think we need
integrity these are words I don't see
thrown around too much I see the word a
lie a lot you know I see the word good
person I see the right side of history
you know I see those kind of things in
the the digital arena but I think we
need to be courageous we need to have
principles not just beliefs you know
because I think there's a difference
between principles and beliefs you can
believe something because it's trendy to
but if you have a principle let's say to
a principle of fairness let's say you
have a principle of fairness that that
sort of determines how you speak to
people that determines what you won't do
even though it's popular too you know
and so I think we need to develop
principles not just beliefs because
beliefs change with the wind you know
they're fads most of the time
ideological fats but you don't fall into
these fads when you have principles I
think we need to be able to trust
ourselves to some degree I think we all
should be more curious and interested in
each other I think we shouldn't assign
ill intent to everybody I think that's
quite paranoid
I think it's self-important because I
think if you're living in the real world
do you understand that most people are
indifferent to your existence it's not
about hating you and even if most people
even understood how much most of us like
hate ourselves to whatever degree you
know we don't have time you know to hate
someone else for the most part we might
have some stereotypes you know there are
stereotypes that we all have about each
other and we can diminish those when we
speak to one another so we have to speak
to one another you know we can't afford
to see every conversation that is let's
say
passionate or difficult as emotional
labor life is emotional labor you know
existing is emotional labor to some
capacity and if these things matter to
you then talk to people so that's all we
have and if this is an awful question as
well I feel those things are getting
worse I don't and that's really sad for
me because I grew up in South London and
I saw things getting better I saw people
becoming more tolerant becoming more
open it feels we've taken a regressive
step back because let's just be clear
when you were growing up people were
properly raised yes they would properly
raise this up for instance I grew up in
a part of South London the the pub down
the road for me was a BMP pub and Indian
flag flying all the time my family
cousins who came over from Venezuela
racially abused called the p-word all
the rest of it and I saw in London and
societies that all get better not get
perfect but get better do you think
we're at real risk of going back to that
place or maybe a different place which
is equally worse I relate to you when
you say that things are getting worse
then I think if we spend enough time
online it can be a very despairing and
very demoralizing and isolating and
that's one of the reasons as to why I
think this movement deserves a lot of
critical analysis and interrogation
because if they believe that they are
speaking for the minorities I don't
believe that they are I think they're
speaking for an ideology you know
because when a black brown person gay
person trans person doesn't subscribe to
these ideas then you know you call them
fascists you know so this is a movement
that is made a lot of people feel
extremely alienated and I think there
are consequences to that alienation and
so maybe it's one of these cases where
it has to get worse before it gets
better I don't know if it's sustainable
to to build a world view on things on
necess
really true or at least not grounded in
facts but then you know when I when I
meet someone who isn't on Twitter you
know I see that glimmer of hope yeah
because yeah Evette but you know but the
problem is is that it's very influential
you know like I have black and mixed
friends from South Hampton who again
they know nothing about race nothing
what's always they are let's say you
know fairly working-class like they get
along with everybody they they they they
everybody anybody of any race you know
and I'm seeing some of them on Instagram
you know just one ie because like I said
I am NOT scrolling I'm brilliant I'll go
in to check a message and then I'll see
like someone from South Anson talking
about every reason why she is a press
now you know and I and she never felt
that way before you know she never saw
herself like that and I don't know if
her now seeing herself for such a lens I
don't know what that does for her you
know and that's my real issue with this
you know I think life is complicated and
tough enough and we are asking people to
essentially view themselves through the
lens of people that you are convinced
dislike them what about the argument
which some people might make it applies
less in your case because if this person
is black you're black then presumably
you would be able to talk about these
issues before but like if a white person
let's say was to say well you know I
have a black friend and you know he
didn't used to think this way and now he
does a lot of people might say well
actually he did think that way he was
just not prepared to talk about it
because because what has happened is the
black lives matter movement has allowed
a voice for people who have otherwise
not been able to speak well yes I think
anybody who is a minority within a
majority I think there are quite natural
things that you could feel you know and
this could work anywhere in the world
you know so there are genuine feelings I
think of maybe sometimes not feeling
like you belong and not feeling like
[Music]
and maybe you know some feelings of
inferiority that you've internalized
through media portrayals and and all of
these kinds of things I think those
things are real however you know that
say a movement might like black lives
matter might might articulate let's say
some of these things that you felt and
didn't know how to put words to
but maybe what's not necessarily there
is that like everybody is against you
you know and make everybody who doesn't
understand your experience he doesn't
understand from a place of racism as
opposed to we are all occupying
different realities you know so let's
say if your world view is completely
comprised of everything you've
experienced why is it so hard to
understand that someone else's is you
know you know and then and I think once
we kind of can understand that we are
all occupying this world in very
different ways I I think that can help
it doesn't have to just because someone
doesn't understand everything about you
and how could they you know we don't
even understand everything about
ourselves you know that doesn't mean
that they are gunning for your downfall
you know and I think again like teaching
people these things to people that you
guys deemed honorable I think I think is
irresponsible do you think we're quite
patronizing the way we see ethnic
minorities in this country in the sense
that you know that how we you know we
can't say this because you know you've
you've got to protect them or whatever
else or do you see where I'm going with
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] going
sometimes see the way that people to you
know discuss these issues and you know
you can't say it like this you've got a
now set like this and it's like they're
an adult they're intelligent they can
decide on their own whether it's whether
they agree or disagree yeah why'd you
feel that you have to protect people
yeah because I guess they don't
recognize the difference between
compassion and pity you know and I think
a lot of people think compassion is pit
know they've mistaken their their pity
for compassion and so when you pity
someone you kind of innately see them as
like below you to some degree you know
lesser intelligence and you know a bit
childlike you know I think they they're
quitting the trope is like the noble
savage you know they're not been able to
think for themselves we must protect
them and that's not something that I
know is all English all white people
doing it's people who were tethered to
the idea of what it means to be a good
person or what it means to be an ally
and that's why we have to be careful
anybody let's say who you know if you or
if you're committed to seeing your life
as a battlefield go for it but you have
to be careful but when you're asking for
a life ship you're not asking people to
[Music]
to pity you you know and to treat you
like a child and to tread on eggshells
around you because nobody who if they if
someone doesn't feel like they can be
honest with you they don't respect you
very much I know that in myself I mean I
try to respect everyone you know a base
sort of universal level however the
people that I think are most intelligent
are the people that I don't tread on
eggshells around you know and you know
more and more I can see people are
inviting in a world view where they're
asking for that you know and it's not
the same as being thoughtful it's not
empathy you know empathy isn't pandering
to your worldview
you know empathy is being able to
understand where you might be coming
from so yeah I do find it incredibly
patronizing but then many people don't
but what I would say to a lot of people
is read the room even though like in the
sense
I think if you if you speak to someone
you can see who needs this sort of
protection hmm and who doesn't you know
but again because people are different
it's not a one-size-fits-all so what one
black person may enjoy and feel is like
you know a lie ship or solidarity
another person just ceases entirely
condescending I would I mean we could
talk for hours and you talk about the
need for courage and clarity on the
stuff I want to acknowledge you for
being courageous and coming on the show
thank you and being very clear about a
lot of the stuff and it's life is
complicated man yeah life is complicated
and we shouldn't undermine that to
promote a narrative because if we're
doing that I just think we're harming
the people that we claim to want to help
we need them to be able to embrace the
grey and because we need them to be able
to embrace that within themselves or at
least at least acknowledges their
embrace the grey well we've got one
final question for you and it's a
question we always finishes with which
is what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be maybe we're not talking
about how easy it is to become the thing
that we dislike and how sometimes the
thing that we strongly dislike in other
people is an unchecked part of ourselves
so maybe we should be talking about our
own capacity for destruction that seems
very active does what's a Nietzsche
quote when you're fighting those who
fight monsters should see to it that
they do not become monsters themselves
when you stare into the abyss the abyss
also stares into you oh it's awakened
people follow you my my Twitter or my
Instagram that my name are you sure
underscore can be that's a why is h8c
underscore a can be a K a and B and
you're working on a book yes I am so
yeah well we'll get you back on talking
about it we've got it out yeah thank you
very much for watching and listening
we'll see you very very soon with
another interview or a live stream
absolutely if we don't get cancelled and
thrown into the river see it soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell buttons next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pot and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word